you walk it's a pleasure to have you
here and Jim Belk I will say did a great
job at setting this up and everybody
else Forrest Frank we're glad to have
you here it's a brand new facility we
moved in 5th 15th of March I think it
was we had a first meeting here at the
first week in April and you all the
first one once for a nighttime meeting
we really seriously like some feedback
from you on how you like the facilities
and what we could do to do things better
because we hope the holes a few more
these a little history at hand
unanswered very very short we're a
public service not-for-profit public
service Research Corporation we've been
around a while we've been here since
1958 as a matter of fact and we do
contract research mainly for the DMV
what's our specialties homeland security
that's something new we've gotten into
over the last few years but we've been
in acquisition management I'll say
support forever okay all the way from
concept development right through to
retirement in a system quickie on answer
that's all I'm gonna say and introduce
Forrest Fred Thank You president Potomac
Jeff end let him take over Thank You
Jeanne as you know my name is Forrest
Frank and it's a great privilege and
honor for me to be here this evening to
welcome you and our speaker mr. James
Bamford will be introduced in a moment
by our vice president for programs bill
Horne I'd like to draw your attention to
the presence of the c-span camera
because this presentation will be
televised I think on a delay basis of
some of us are sensitive to imagery and
those of us who are uncomfortable being
on an imaged are welcome to join me in
the back right hand corner where we will
be behind and out
our age I'd like to extend a special
thanks to Jean and Jim Belk and all the
other fine folks here at answer we're
welcoming us into their wonderful new
conference facility this is a delightful
place to be here great time and wish you
much success to her in your future
endeavors just a couple of business
items the next chapter event will be a
luncheon on May 17th on Sunday May 20th
will be the national awards banquet I
hope all of you will be able to attend
you will also note at the entrance to
this facility as a flyer announcing the
1991 opens for solutions conference nmi
a members were offered a 10% discount
from appropriate fees and I'd encourage
those of you who aren't going to be
there with bill Horne helping trying to
attend if possible this is a wonderful
event it's very worthwhile and Robert
Steele who is the organizer of this
event always rewards our chapter with a
substantial contribution for our
volunteer help it is contributions such
as that we get from from Robert that
enable us to host an event like this
tonight we're delighted and encourage
everyone to participate later in the
evening we will announce the results of
our chapter elections I don't think we
have them exactly yet anyone who hasn't
yet voted please see Lori and we'll be
happy to give you a chance to
participate also at the conclusion of
this evening's presentation those of you
who promised to pay by credit card would
you please see mr. golden we raise your
hand our credit card machine has arrived
now if you don't see him he's going to
see you as will mr. Belk and yeah I got
to belfry fire
I can't tell you what you did but I
don't think it'd be good if you haven't
paid on that let me introduce if I may
our vice president for programs mr. bill
Horne Thank You Forrest it's my pleasure
to have the honor of introducing Jim
Bamford might mention that at the
conclusion of this period after mr.
Bamford answers some questions we will
leave this conference room we'd like to
all clear out so the cleaners can go to
work in here and go out where the food
and drink are and the books and there'll
be some more books available for sale
and also more autographs given it looks
like we've got way ahead of it on the
books already so it's a pretty good deal
the words of mr. Bamford are his own and
so Nami a takes no position on the
accuracy or the factual basis of his
presentation but we are very pleased
this time to have such a honored author
what we think has written an important
book that will have a real impact in the
dialogue in this country on the
intelligences James Bamford having just
completed the body of Secrets the
anatomy of the ultra secret NSA from the
Cold War
the dawn of the new century published by
doubleday
this is a sequel to his award-winning
the puzzle palace which made him a
reputation both welcome and unwelcome
within the intelligence community
depending on where you sat in this
situation but certainly earned him a
place as one of the authorities writing
on the National Security Agency in on
national security subjects James Bamford
was for nine years until 1998 Washington
investigative producer for ABC News
World News Tonight with Peter Jennings
he was responsible for long-term
in-depth investigative stories from
concept to final airing a wide range of
topics included from the White House
scandals to locating spies in Cold War
Europe to finding murderers in the
Middle East many involved complicated
investigations and difficult areas of
the world such as locating principal
figures involved in the Clinton
campaigns finance scandal
hiding in China his recipient of
numerous TV reporting awards including
the Overseas Press Club award for
excellence the Society for Professional
Journalists deadlines award for the best
investigative reporting on TV he has
written on investigative topics for many
national magazines including cover
stories for the New York Times Magazine
on iran-contra Washington Post magazine
the on the shoot-down of the KL
double-oh-seven
flight the Los Angeles Times magazine on
the Mafia he's got another one coming
out the New York Times Book Review for
this next Sunday as his book as the lead
item here I'm told it's a very favorable
review
he's written dozens of op-ed pieces and
book reviews the New York Times
Washington Post the LA Times some of you
may have seen him on TV or heard him on
radio here just in the last several days
he's certainly getting around I've heard
him twice unlike the interviews he's
testified on intelligence and security
issues before committees of Senate and
the House of
it is with great pleasure and
anticipation
I welcome James Bamford I want to thank
Bill and very nice introduction I really
appreciate it and gene I want to thank
you for the hospitality of having this
session here and let me speak here in
your beautiful building and for us
thanks very much for having me a speaker
on your organizationís terrific writing
about NSA and secret parts of government
benefits and deficits the when I did the
puzzle palace the problem was when I
wrote the book almost nobody knew what
NSA was when I wrote it
my editors at Hope Mifflin at the time
thought I was writing a novel at first I
think it was six months into it that
they began to realize this was a real
agency I'm writing about one of the
funny things was when I was on my book
tour after the puzzle palace came out
one of the people that I had to share a
car with going to one of the TV sessions
was Bill Bradley Senator Bill Bradley
from New Jersey and in the back of the
taxi he said what's your book about and
I said it's about NSA the National
Security Agency and he said what's that
so I spent the rest of the taxi ride
explaining with the largest intelligence
agency was when we got on the TV show he
went first he was talking about the
economy and then they asked me about NSA
and the first question was how secret is
it how secret is NSA and I just couldn't
resist it I said even senator Bradley
said he'd never heard of it
and so he got very angry after that I
think I had to take the separate taxi
back and as aide called me up the next
day so that was a very low blow I said
no I was just telling the truth I said
it for I wanted a low blow I would have
said he confused it with the NBA
but also when the book came out there
was a every author wants to get on The
Book of the Month Club so you look at
the back of the New York Times where
they put your little little picture of
your book tiny little picture of it and
so Book of the Month Club picked my book
and and I looked at the back of the New
York Times Book Review and and there it
was but they had changed something and
said instead of saying a report on NSA
America's most secret agency they
changed it and said a report on NASA
America's most secret agency because the
ad company thought I had made a mistake
on the jacket of my book and they
voluntarily changed it for Misa at least
the NSA is a little bit better known now
one of the other problems I had when
when the book came out they went to I go
into a book store and ask you know my
book is there and sometimes I go around
look to see if the book is is where it
should be and I don't see it I'd asked
for it see if it's in the book store and
one of the things that used to bother me
was when I didn't see it and I go ask
for it and the clerk would say well yes
we have four copies of it and I'd say
where is it and they'd say it's in the
puzzle section so I definitely changed
the name of the book this time the body
of secrets and the problem I had this
time however was try to be a little cute
it was body of secrets as an anatomy of
America's ultra secret NSA and then all
the chapter titles or body parts brain
for all about the computer's hard about
the internal workings of NSA and so
forth and then I began running out of
body parts and I didn't know what
chapter to name you know gall bladder or
something like that so but this time was
a little bit different NSA was a lot
more cooperative and they opened the
door crack for me to take a peek in and
director Hayden was very nice and gave
me a number of interviews and tours and
all that type of thing and they're even
having a book signing for me up at NSA
tomorrow so it's a different reaction
than the last time so I guess at the end
of the Cold War and the number of years
sort of mellows everybody
let me just tell you a little bit about
what this books about first of all I
wanted to there's been a lot of books on
world war ii the ultra and breaking of
the purple code and all that so i wanted
to start on the de world war ii ended
basically and what i started with was
very interesting it's a something that
few people ever knew about and what
happened was that as a war was coming to
an end he had all these cryptologists
who were in Bletchley Park and watched
the war vicariously like Boyer's almost
through the messages of the messages of
the the enemy and then as the war was
coming to an end the decision was made
to take a lot of these cryptologists
from the monastery there in Bletchley
Park and put him right in the front
lines which really surprised a lot of
them he had some of these people going
out for gun practice and they weren't
very good at shooting guns and they were
very nervous about being parachuted into
the front lines but the whole idea
behind this operation it was called ti'
comm which is short for target committee
and the idea was a joint committee
between our joint project between the
British and the Americans and the idea
was to fly the cryptologists to the
frontlines drop them in there and have
them capture as many code machines
cipher machines from the Germans as
possible as many cryptologists from the
German German cryptologist as possible
the reason for that they had two
principal reasons for doing that one was
to get there before the Russians got
there because if they figured that the
Germans were able to break us or British
ciphers they wanted to get there and get
those machines and get those people
before the Russians got in and found it
and the second reason was to capture
whatever the the Germans might have in
terms of breaking Russian ciphers
because I knew that they had been
working on Russian ciphers for for quite
a while so they they weren't able to
parachute in the front lines because the
war started disintegrating towards the
end and
they so they wrote in on on jeeps and
trucks to the pretty much the front
lines and they had one major they had a
lot of discoveries one of the things
they discovered was that the Germans
never did break any major u.s. ciphers
which made them very happy
a couple low-level ciphers a couple
lowered naval ciphers they broke but but
none of the major ciphers so they felt
fairly confident about their about us is
own cipher system then they went after
the Germans to find out what they knew
about the Russian system and they were
very successful about that they they
found these German prisoners and and one
of the Allied prison camps who worked on
cipher machines and so forth and during
an interrogation they told him that we
they had broken the Russian principle
cipher one of their high-level ciphers
and that they know where the machine is
that broken the machine had been hidden
under the ground under the front of one
of the German buildings so the the
American and British cypher people went
there and dug it up and it was a huge
machine it filled up for ten ton trucks
a giant machine and and they set it up
and they had the the Germans there show
him how to work it and lo and behold
they had managed to find a key to
breaking the Russian cipher very early
on which was very lucky because they
hadn't had never even attacked it never
even tried to break it during the entire
war with a small exception of this
Venona project which was very small and
and only had to do with the number of
messages previously intercepted and and
mostly had to do with the KGB code and
so forth so this was a major advance for
the code breakers in the US and Britain
and that lasted until 1948 and in 1948
everything just went silent and NSA's
ears went totally deaf at that point
because the Russians have managed to
have a spy
and the predecessor to NSA at the time
and that spy I gave away the key secrets
to that machine that that the
predecessor at NSA was using to break
the codes so at that point the Russian
government ordered that no more signals
be sent through the air that land lines
be used and made major improvements in
its cipher system and throughout most of
the 1950s the NSA was basically deaf
during basically death in terms of
trying to eavesdrop on high-level
Russian ciphers President Eisenhower in
late 50s became very worried about it
and I've got documents from the
Eisenhower library that been recently
Declassified where he's talking about
the problem and he's right in the Oval
Office he's saying we've got to break
the Russian code and so forth and he he
started this project lightning which was
one of the largest government finance
projects in history up to that time in
terms of building up the u.s. computer
strength and that was gonna be the key
to helping to break some of these
Russian ciphers so the American computer
industry got a major the the pump for
the computer industry got primed with
this project lightning a great deal of
money went into it and the American
computer industry really took off after
that during the early 60s I write about
the that's basically the Bay of Pigs and
the Cuban Missile Crisis and there have
been dozens of books written on the
Cuban Missile Crisis but not one even
mentions NSA during what intro NSA plate
if you see that recent movie 13 days the
NSA gets mentioned once during the
entire movie but NSA did play a major
role in the Cuban Missile Crisis
although those secrets have never come
out so I'm writing about them basically
for the first time in my book a lot of
them and it was a really interesting
period because the US had listening
posts all around the the Soviet
and we're picking up indications of when
they were sending ships out and the
ships would try to mask where they were
going they would send out signals saying
we're leaving from Black Sea and going
to Africa or something but then through
high-frequency direction-finding they'd
find the ships aren't going to Africa
they were going to Cuba and a lot of
times they'd be on their official
broadcast be lying about what was being
loaded in terms of cargo
but NSA was able to pick up what the
real cargo was and a lot of the ships
and all of a sudden they had all these
passenger ships going to Cuba loaded
with thousands of passengers when most
Russians can't get out to take vacations
and Cuba very often so they figure these
were all the people going to work on the
missiles and so forth so NSA played a
large role in terms of getting the
government's attention the
administration's attention to looking at
Cuba it was the the Air Force actually
flying a u2 that picked up the first
indications of the first photos of the
of the missiles but NSA had a major ship
the USS Oxford sitting right off havana
harbor it was only six miles off of
vannah harbor and it would just go back
and forth and the Cubans knew exactly
what it was there for and they would
harass it a lot of times it fly planes
low or they send torpedo boats out and
point their guns at the ship and try to
intimidate it and the people on the ship
were you know trying to pick up as many
signals as possible and they knew it was
a hazardous area but at one point they
picked up a key signal and that was the
activation of one of the of the missiles
I mean we knew they had missiles before
but once they heard the signal from the
missile from the warhead basically they
knew that the missiles were activated at
that moment which was a there was
another milestone in NSA actually flew a
helicopter over and picked up the tape
and got it back to NSA right away during
the one of the hairiest times for the
crew members I interviewed quite a few
of the crew members was during Kennedy's
broadcast that night because they didn't
really have
a sense of how really really how
dangerous it was and then they heard in
live on the radio the Kennedy address
and they're looking out their polar
portals and seen Havana Harbor only six
miles away and they were getting very
nervous since the if you know anything
or ever came they were the first ones
they were gonna go but they played an
important role during that entire period
a role that really hasn't been talked
about much so I get into that quite a
bit in the book from there I go into
Vietnam NSA's role in Vietnam has never
been written about and it took a lot of
research because NSA just starting to
sort of declassify some of that but it's
an important role the very first person
ever killed in Vietnam and during the
Vietnam War was an army signals
intelligence person trying to do
Direction finding I think was 1961 the
reason the u.s. committed itself very
heavily was because of NSA to a large
degree it was during the Gulf of Tonkin
incident for example the Gulf of Tonkin
incident came about because one of the
ships the USS Maddox was a eavesdropping
ship it was a ship just collecting
signals along the coast of Vietnam and
at the same time the the at the same
time the ship was cruising up and down
and collecting signals the US was
sponsoring these attacks along the coast
and the North Vietnamese connected the
two they thought that the ships were
directing these these attacks on the
coast and to some degree that's what the
United States wanted them to do because
then they would be able to get a lot
more signals the problem was by
connecting the the thematics with the
attacks on the shore the North
Vietnamese then came out and attacked
the Maddox at one point where they
attempted to attack at the
they missed that one on the first
attempt and then about two days later
well after that first attempt the u.s.
put another ship an escort ship there to
to protect it it was called the turn of
joy and about two days later a day and a
half later so the maddox got a emergency
message from NSA saying that they're
about to be attacked and that night was
very foggy and the Maddox and the turn
of joy began seeing all these images on
their radar scopes indicating that that
attacks are taking place and torpedoes
are being shot at the ship and so forth
it wasn't until and after that President
Johnson got very upset and that's when
the Congress passed almost unanimously
the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution based on
these incidents but it wasn't until
years later that it was discovered that
that message that most important message
the warning message that went out to the
Maddox was a mistake that message was
about the previous attack two days
earlier and the message just went out
late so there will never was a message
indicating that they were about to be
attacked the second night and it was
later determined that most of what they
were seeing on those radar scopes
because it was a foggy night and all
that were sort of ghost images so no
attack ever took place that second night
but that was what basically led to the
Gulf of Tonkin Resolution in 1964 so in
as they played a major role in
advertently in the entire launching of
the u.s. formal entry into the war
during the Vietnam War was the NSA
played a major role in trying to
eavesdrop on virtually all the signals
in in Vietnam they had people on the
ground that would do direction-finding
trying to find out where the Vietcong
were and it was an extremely dangerous
job and that's the job that the
sergeant Davis who was the first person
killed was doing at the time and then it
was like a wedding cake in terms of the
way the eavesdropping was done over over
Vietnam he had the people on the ground
then you had another level which was the
helicopters and then small one in two
engine planes and then the four engine
eavesdropping playing singing planes and
eventually you get up to the they had
you twos that were flying off the coast
and they would be monitoring signals and
it was a very boring job for the You
Tube pilots because unlike when they're
flying the photo missions and they're
actually flying over things and taking
pictures and snapping turning things on
and off with the second missions they
were basically just a relay station and
so they fly these circle circular
patterns over over the Gulf of Tonkin
and pick up the signals and then just
relay them to a down downlink down in
safe area of South Vietnam so you had
and then above the u2's were the sr-71
that would fly in from Kadena Air Force
Base in Okinawa and they'd leave in the
morning and fly their mission and fly
back and they're back in time for lunch
and their entire time I think it was
over Vietnam was was and that's back and
forth was only 12 minutes any rate would
have collect an enormous amount of
signals and then there was still the
rc-135 which was like a vacuum cleaner
that picked up all these signals and
then they had drones that were picking
up more signals so there was a huge
effort to do this one of the problems
one of the major factors for us losses
in Vietnam however was the opposite side
of the coin senior US military officials
there were pretty sloppy when it came to
communication security the NSA did a
huge report on hold this entire problem
was called deadly transmissions and
that's what it was because a lot of the
signals there was a lot of
misunderstanding about the
sophistication of the Viet Cong and the
North Vietnamese Army
you know they saw these people wearing
these tire treads for sandals and so
forth so a lot of the senior military
didn't think they'd be very
sophisticated but eventually when they
started discovering some of these
hideouts that they had they found reams
of transcripts of high-level US military
communications because a lot of military
commanders were too lazy to use
encryption systems they use the regular
open telephone which was heavily
penetrated by the North Vietnamese and
Viet Cong so in addition to that the
Russians had a ship sitting off an
intelligence collection ship sitting off
Guam at the time we were flying the
b-52s and NSA did a survey around Guam
after a while and began finding out
they're picking up a lot of signals and
and the pilots when they were
transmitting information on the way to
Vietnam that information was being
picked up also so there were a lot of
not only a lot of times when the b-52s
ended up bombing areas where there was
nobody there because the Vietcong had
found out about earlier there were times
when when the Vietnamese actually turned
the turn the tables and found out US
access codes or a lot of times there
were no access codes to some of this
some of the military activities and they
would make up or they'd find out what
the code words were and and pretend they
were a US you know somebody in the army
and they'd send a helicopter to go to a
place that where they had an ambush
waiting so the communication security
was a very critical part of the whole
Vietnam War it was a critical part for
the Vietnamese doing as well as they did
it was a critical part for the u.s.
losses in a lot of occasions during the
latter stages of the war well let me
just move to the basically the last days
of the war which was very interesting I
was able to get from NSA a great deal of
the
intercepts do it really intercepts but
the last days of the war when Saigon was
falling you had a taskforce out in the
Tonkin Gulf that was waiting for a lot
of the people who are leaving the
embassy to fly by a helicopter out to
the ships and so forth but the commander
of the task force was too large to be
blind of what was going on at the
Embassy at the time and and what was
taking place so they asked NSA to
basically monitor embassy communications
and then pass all the basically
intercepts on to the commander of the
task force and I quote from a lot of
those intercepts in the book and it's a
fascinating tale of the last hours of
Saigon in the last hours of that Embassy
there because what you're doing is
you're listening to the actual words of
what's happening as the whole embassy
complex is collapsing and how they're
trying to get the Ambassador out and the
only reason you know were able to
determine this is from the messages that
NSA was forwarding to the commands the
NSA had had a major disaster at the at
the very end one of its biggest
disasters I think in his history one of
the things that well at the Embassy they
did very well and trying to destroy all
the equipment and so forth before the
before the city fell but as the war was
coming to an end the u.s. tried to get a
lot of the encryption equipment back
from the South Vietnamese because they
had let them use some of the NSA's
sophisticated encryption equipment
during the during the war and and
actually during the period 1972 seventy
five also but then it's 1975 came along
that's the date when Saigon fell in
April of 1975 for about six months
before that they began trying to get all
this encryption equipment back from from
the South Vietnamese government because
they didn't want it to fall in the hands
of the North Vietnamese government and
they did a good job of accounting for it
and getting it all back and
put it in this warehouse at-at Townsend
at Airport and it was right next to the
Armed Forces courier station which was
going to take all the equipment back
well unfortunately the city fell before
they were able to get all that equipment
back so there were about 700 pieces of
pristine high-level NSA cipher equipment
that that the Vietnamese captured when
they captured the city and which is
probably the largest single loss of
encryption equipment in US history see I
want to take questions so I don't want
to prolong this too long but I get into
the a lot of areas one of the most
important areas like get into in the
book I think is the attack on the USS
Liberty it's a very controversial area
because it was during the six-day war in
1967 Israel attacked the ship during
broad daylight
they sent fighters that shot about 800
rounds into the ship 800 cannon rounds
they fired rockets into the ship
I dropped bombs on the ship and I came
back and they leveled napalm all over
the ship this is a spy ship NSA
eavesdropping ship it was 13 miles off
the coast of the Sinai when all this
took place the crew the ship was very
lightly armed there were only defensive
machine guns that could only reach about
a mile or so that was the total length
of the of the machine guns after the
aircraft really let the Liberty have it
then a number of well there were three
torpedo boats that came and they fired a
total of five torpedoes at the ship
luckily only one hit but that one that
hit hit right in the signals
intelligence space is killing
twenty-five intercept operators
immediately they were totaled 34 people
killed on the ship 171 wounded the hole
that was blasted into the ship was big
enough to drive a bus into
I think was 44 feet wide or something
like that it was huge and despite it all
the ship managed to survive and the
captain captain McGonagall managed to
get the ship back to safety the question
is what happened during that that period
of time again this is broad daylight the
Israelis had done a tremendous amount of
surveillance of the ship beforehand they
had sent planes going over and coming
back and and the crew members every one
of them says that the flags were flying
during the entire attack in addition to
that the names were on the back of the
the name was on the back of the ship USS
Liberty and it's markings were all on
American style naval markings on the
ship I did a lot of research on this
largely through new NSA documents I was
able to obtain NSA looked into this very
extensively the conclusions of a lot of
the people senior people at NSA was that
it was deliberate primarily because
there was no other possible explanation
the ship was not flying an Egyptian flag
was not carrying any Egyptian equipment
or script on the side yet the Israelis
said they thought it was an Egyptian
ship and the ship they they said they
thought it was was a ship that had been
sitting at a port 200 miles away and it
never left her in the entire war and
what it was was a troop and horse
transport about 1/3 the size of the of
the Liberty in addition they said they
made a mistake they thought the Liberty
was going 30 knots and and it was
outpacing their PT boats delivery
Liberty at the time was going about
between 3 & 5 knots in its top speed was
17 knots the they said they thought the
Liberty was bombarding a LaRouche which
was a city on the Sinai desert about 13
miles away the the guns on the Liberty
were only these machine guns which had a
total distance of
Miele so there are all these
explanations that made no sense in
addition one of the things I discovered
was that at the time the Liberty was off
the coast of the Sinai there were
massive war crimes taking place on the
Sinai desert the Israelis were killing
Egyptian prisoners by the hundreds and
this has been reported not only in the
New York Times in the Washington Post
but the Israeli papers because the
historians the Israeli military
historians have come out and told about
this
they wrote a report on these these
massacres during right after the event
and then the Israeli government covered
it up so what you have was all this
activity taking place on the Sinai he
had an eavesdropping ship 13 miles away
that the Israelis knew about because
they had flown all the all the
surveillance missions and even one of
the the naval one of the naval officers
in the Naval Command said that he had
identified the liberty through jane's
fighting ship and passed on that
identification so the bottom line was
that Israel did an investigation they
prosecuted nobody they demoted nobody
most of the people involved eventually
went on high careers and so forth the
u.s. never did any investigation
whatsoever they had a couple small
inquiries into the problems with the
communications getting messages to him
from the Liberty they had in a naval
court of inquiry that looked into the
performance of the sailors on the ship
whether they performed well and so forth
but the US government never did one
investigation into why this happened
unlike the USS Cole for example which
you know the day after it happened they
were plane loads of FBI agents flying to
Yemen this never had it there were twice
as many people killed in this incident
Congress never held an investigation I
mean Congress can look into spend weeks
looking into why people were fired in a
travel office in the White House but
they can't look into wide 34 people I
don't know and a u.s. ship was virtually
destroyed
so anyway this came under my purview was
writing about NSA was the worst loss of
life in NSA history and the conclusions
I come up with or you know the u.s.
should have an investigation even 34
years later we should look into what
happened it's only fair for the families
of the victims and the survivors who are
still alive and in the chapters I go
also into the problems that are cropping
up now which is is NSA going deaf is NSA
starting to lose its hearing because of
all the changes in technology I also
discussed the the question of Ashkelon
this whole thing that has the Europeans
upset whether NSA is eavesdropping on
foreign countries and so forth
there are commercial communications I
was invited to Brussels to speak before
the European Union the European
Parliament on on Monday and I went there
and I totaled that in two books on NSA
and having written more than anybody
else I've never found one indication
that NSA picks up information from
European companies and passes it on to
American companies which didn't exactly
make them very happy but and then they
began two hours of two and a half hours
of interrogation as though I was the NSA
why are you sending these these you know
he's dropping on us and so forth but it
was a fun book to write because it was
like exploring a lost continent since
hardly anybody had ever traveled on
these roads before in terms of writing
it and you know if you all come back in
20 years I'll have the third of my
trilogy finish about this time we could
speak here again anyway I'd like to take
whatever questions we can
my name is Scott Palmer and I'd like to
know if what you told us about the
interim period after World War two
before NSA is that covered in your book
yes that's I start off with that in the
book that's the first very first chapter
yes thank the price of admission well
thanks very much yeah ty comm is still
considered very secret by both the US
and the British government yeah
the US government wanted to release Tyco
on the details of it and it's long sorry
I won't bore you with it but the British
objected to it and because the British
objected to it the US government still
never officially released documents the
documents I have just happened to be
sitting in the NSA Museum library so
open to anybody wants to look at them
yes any other questions yes sir
yes William horn do you have anything on
the Pueblo incident that you find
anything in that area yeah I did a whole
chapter on the Pueblo also the Pueblo
was a ship attacked off or captured by
the the North Vietnamese 1968 I North
North Korean sorry they're captured by
North Korea in 1968 and January of 1968
and one of the interesting things about
that which which I discovered was that
that was captured in January of 1968 and
having talked to a number of the former
KGB KGB people it was a major success
for the the Russians because they were
able to capture the machines that were
on the on the Pueblo just like the
Chinese were able to capture all that
equipment on the ep-3 now but when the
Chinese were actually when the North
Vietnamese I'm sorry
the North Koreans when they captured the
Pueblo and got the machines off and pass
it on to the Russians they had half the
puzzle the Russians at half the puzzle
they had the machines but they didn't
have the key cards the things that
actually changed the codes every day so
that loss wasn't that important but when
nobody knew for over a decade was that
almost at the same time the previous
November John Walker began passing all
the key cards to the Russians so between
the time of 1967 and 1985 the Russians
had both the machines and the key cards
so they were able to to break a lot of
the high-level read a lot of the
higher-level encrypted communications
for over a decade because of that
oh yes sir Thank You Patrick Ryan on the
Liberty incident can you talk a little
bit about the reaction among those in
the NSA who believed it was a deliberate
attack if they tried to get the story
straight or get the story out as they
saw it or if there was any effort to
suppress the story also since you've
written about it - have you been
contacted or has anyone approached you
about as a position that that you're
putting forward either from the US
government or the Israeli government the
book just came out a couple of days ago
so nobody's you know nobody's approached
me really in any way in terms of the the
NSA reaction I interviewed Marshall
Carter the director of NSA a number of
years ago for the puzzle palace I spent
two days with him interviewing him and
he was very extent gave me a very
extensive interview most of what I wrote
about it in the puzzle palace one of the
things he did tell me that he didn't
want printed at the time was that he
believed that it was a deliberate attack
I have it in in this book here in the
body of secrets loot or della for
example he wrote an internal memo
memorandum for the record very soon
afterwards and that memorandum has never
come out until I write about in my book
here and he said he was very had a lot
of foresight I think he said that the
only explanation he could come up with
basically was that some commander on the
Sinai I was doing something he didn't
want the u.s. to find out about general
Morrison who was the head of the
operations at NSA at the time he's
actually deputy head of operations at
NSA at the time said there there can't
be any other explanation Walter Dealey
who did the investigation for NSA
concluded that the Israelis had to know
because of the extensive intelligence
they had there's a one thing that just
came up that I just discovered a
basically in the last few weeks which
was very interesting a matter of fact -
Norman Paul Meyers book here is a matter
on the NAU - there's a quote in there
from a from another book called
stalemate and it was a book written by
one of the officials at the Embassy in
Israel he was there from 1967 until 19
for about three years I guess it was and
he wrote in his book that he was told by
one of the other officials the deputy
chief of mission at the US Embassy in
Tel Aviv that in 1970 while the u.s. was
flying these patrols YouTube patrols
over the the Suez Canal to watch what
whether either side was violating the
the treaty that Moshe Dayan called him
over to his office and threatened him by
saying that if any of those u2's flied
over in our airspace we're going to
shoot it down I mean if that's the
mindset that you know we catch you doing
any spying we're gonna shoot it down yes
Norman
just a question not a comment rather a
commander in the Sinai committing an
atrocity
let's give him credit for that or give
him the label of committing the atrocity
was able to call the Israeli Operations
Center for the Air Force in Tel Aviv for
the Navy in Haifa to get both of them to
go along with directing fighters and PT
boats to attack a ship to cover for him
well what happened was that the the
original request for this whole attack
came from a commander in the Sinai I
mean even the Israelis admit this but
what they're saying is the commander
said were being bombarded by a ship out
at sea and that was the reason the
Israelis give for launching it
originally well how could they be
bombarded by the Liberty it doesn't you
know it doesn't his guns couldn't even
reach more than a mile let alone 13 14
15 miles to the to the town of El Arish
find them an aircraft where Air Force or
Navy personnel they were both I think
well maybe not but the the original
person that identified it from the
Jane's fighting ships was the naval a
naval liaison to the israeli air force
office and he passed it on to the deputy
chief of naval operations so you know
this is a the problem is I don't have
the the money or the time to investigate
every last detail of this case the point
I'm trying to make with this chapter is
the US government has an obligation to
do it and and there's enough I graduated
from law school and one of the things
you learn in law school is when you're
building a case you've built up probable
cause well there's enough probable cause
to show that the Israelis did it
deliberately it's not definitive proof
but I can't that's not my job is to come
up with definitive proof - to show
there's probable cause if the US
government should conduct its own
investigation
is what I think they should do one other
little point on that was was one other
thing I found was the Israelis
continually said they never saw the
American flag even though every member
of the crew said the flag was flying
during this entire time and one of the
people I found was a one of the things
nobody knew at the time was that the NSA
also had a plane flying above the
Liberty during the during the incident
and I talked to the the guy who was a
chief Hebrew Russian linguist he was
dual language capable and he said that
in the information they picked up from
the pilots and also the PT boats there
was mention of the US flag so I you know
that's what he that's what he had to say
yes released the gun camera film from
the aircraft that made the attack you
might want to check with the embassy and
try to get access to it because the gun
camera film which I've seen is very
interesting because the smoke from the
ship is going straight up it wasn't
going straight up before they attacked
it and and you know you got all these
pilots there that those USS Liberty is
in big letters in the back and they had
the PT boat crew that was there too so I
mean you know tell that to the crew one
of the things the captain of the ship
McGonigle never said a word about the
the weather it was deliberate or
accidental or who we believed or
anything during the entire 34 years and
he was awarded the Medal of Honor for
his courageousness and then the Johnson
administration managed to make an
exception in his case and not presented
at the White House by the president they
gave it to him in a back room of the
Naval Yard by the Secretary of the Navy
again trying to hide this whole thing
anyway so during his entire post naval
career he never said a word about it
until he was almost on his deathbed it
was four months before he died and he
finally said I think that the Israelis
did it deliberately and there needs to
be an investigation you know that's what
these people are saying and I just agree
with them that there needs to be an
investigation so so we could now get
some definitive answers here rather
have some hack journalists here go out
and you know find out what he can I mean
we got an entire Congress and and
Federal Bureau of Investigation
everybody else that were supposed to be
doing official investigations but anyway
I really enjoyed being here and I you
know have a thrill to talk to people in
the community I wish I could be asking
you all these questions now so thanks
very much I appreciate it